[Music]
foreign
welcome to this special edition of
Hannity I'm Tammy Bruce in for Sean and
we begin with more bad news for Joe
Biden the walls are actually closing in
House Republicans are now demanding
records regarding three pseudonyms Biden
used to conduct official business as
vice president this includes government
emails about Ukraine mysteriously sent
to both Joe and Hunter Biden meanwhile
two former vice presidential aides to
Joe Biden with close ties to Hunter and
his investment firm might soon face
Congressional scrutiny according to
foxnews.com both of these aides had jobs
with Hunter linked firms and worked with
the big guy inside the government when
he was VP so much for that imaginary
wall between the government and Hunter
this summer Biden's adult son was even
reportedly living at the white house for
at least two straight weeks to the
surprise of many staffers Hunters
ill-fated deal is now under
investigation at the house Judiciary
Committee but the bad news does not stop
there remember that special counsel
investigation into Joe Biden's
mishandling of classified documents that
was seemingly going nowhere apparently
Federal prosecutors are now in
negotiations with Biden's attorneys
about the terms of a possible interview
needless to say President Biden seems to
be getting a little nervous and was
noticeably rattled at today's short
press conference watch this
I make I have no comment on any
investigation that's going on that's up
to the justice department and that's all
I have to say now I would yield to who
am I yielding to
distinguished yes the president of the
Republic of Korea
we needed the voice of God to tell us
excuse me this is falling off
there you go
and uh thank you this concludes our
press conference please please stay
seated as the leaders depart please
please stay seated
thank you
we're winning all the competition
[Music]
nobody cares the impression this man is
making my goodness earlier in the day he
was also not pleased with the press and
refused to answer any questions take a
look at this
I'm politely asked the press to to lead
thank you for coming in
China's economy collapsing sir thank you
so much
look on his face that switched to that
weird smile tells you everything doesn't
it hey Sean Hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to Fox News YouTube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else